Well, only a little while ago we were in Exodus 3 where God appeared to Moses in a burning
bush at Mount Horab.
And now he is going to return to this same place with the people of Israel.
So I'd like for us to turn to Exodus 19 to see this together this morning.
So if you have a Bible, please take it and turn with me to Exodus 19.
And as we read this together, you might notice that it doesn't say Mount Horab, it says Mount Sinai.
Nonetheless, this is the same place with different names.
Sinai is the word Sinai is very closely related in Hebrew to the word for bush.
Alright, so we're coming back to the same place where God appeared to Moses in this burning bush.
And there in Exodus 3 when he appeared to Moses in the burning bush, it's interesting.
He told Moses that there was coming a day when he was going to return to that same place.
And there the people would serve the Lord.
So let's read Exodus 19.
We'll begin reading in verse 1.
We'll read down to verse 9.
And then we will read verses 16 down to 19.
On the third new moon after the people of Israel had gone out of the land of Egypt.
On that day they came into the wilderness of Sinai.
They set out from Refidem and came into the wilderness of Sinai.
And they encamped in the wilderness.
There Israel encamped before the mountain.
While Moses went up to God, the Lord called to him out of the mountain saying,
Thus you shall say to the house of Jacob and tell the people of Israel,
You yourselves have seen what I did to the Egyptians and how I bore you on Eagle's wings
and brought you to myself.
Now therefore, if you will indeed obey my voice and keep my covenants,
you shall be my treasured possession among all peoples for all the earth is mine.
You shall be to me a kingdom of priests and a holy nation.
These are the words that you shall speak to the people of Israel.
So Moses came and called to the elders of Israel and set before them all the words that the Lord had
commanded him.
All the people answered together and said,
All that the Lord has spoken, we will do.
And Moses reported the words of the people to the Lord.
And the Lord said to Moses,
Behold, I am coming to you in a thick cloud that the people may hear when I speak with you.
And may believe you forever.
On the morning of the third day, there were thunders and lightnings and a thick cloud
on the mountain and a very loud trumpet blast
so that all the people in the camp trembled.
Then Moses brought the people out of the camp to meet God.
And they took their stand at the foot of the mountain.
Now Mount Sinai was wrapped in smoke because the Lord had descended on it in fire.
The smoke of it went up like the smoke of a kiln and the whole mountain trembled.
And as the sound of the trumpet grew louder and louder, Moses spoke and God answered him
in thunder.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
But as we come before you now, I pray that you would make us
more acutely aware that we are approaching the same God who spoke in this way at Mount Sinai.
Lord, I pray that you would come before us,
we would come before you rather in both reverence and faith as well
with hearts that are attentive and ready to hear the words that you would have to say to us this
morning. We pray this in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen. Well there's something about mountains that capture our imaginations.
A few years ago I read a book, I don't know if any of you have read called
Into Thin Air by John Crackauer. It's a great book but it's about a tragic event.
It was not an exodus, we're going to get there.
It was about an Everest expedition that he went on with some others and it went awry
and in the end there were eight of the team that were traveling together who died
in this tragic accident. And as he reflected on this tragedy, one of the things that he looked back on
critically was the commercialization of Everest climbs that were happening at the time.
So instead of just reserving that for the kind of experts or people that were well trained
for this, basically anybody who could afford to go on an Everest expedition
could be taken up at the right price. And this lack of respect for the terrain that people
were stepping into proved deadly for some of them and others who were climbing Everest as well.
Well this morning we're approaching another mountain. It's Mount Sinai, this great mountain
in Scripture. And we're going to be at this mountain actually for the rest of the book of exodus.
So from this point on in the book this is where it takes place. Moses is going to ascend this
mountain seven times but this mountain is not one that is to be approached lightly.
That isn't because of the difficulty of the terrain of the mountain but rather because of
the God who descends upon this mountain. That's why they're not to approach the mountain lightly.
Because Yahweh Himself descends upon this mountain. And here as we've just read that His
presence on the mountain is manifested now not just with a single burning bush but now
on all the mountain you've got thunder and lightning and fire and smoke and this loud
trumpet that is sounding. When He came down we're told that the very mountain trembled.
The people feared so you might say the people trembled with this mountain. No doubt they did
as the floor beneath the ground beneath their feet trembled. You see in the lead-up to this
the people were given some instructions to prepare for the day. They were to
consecrate themselves. And when the time came they were to approach the mountain
but they were not to touch the mountain. There was a boundary that was put between them and the mountain.
If they were to cross that boundary and touch the mountain they would die, we're told. And all of
this was a visible demonstration of the God who was speaking at that mountain. Because this God is
highly exalted and He is holy. The implication then is when He speaks we listen.
So the thing that we're going to focus on this morning isn't so much the dramatic
manifestation that takes place at the end of the chapter here at Mount Sinai but rather
the calling that the people of God are given at the beginning of the chapter.
So this is the God who is speaking so what is He saying to His people? That's what we're going
to listen to. And what He says to them is really summarized there in verses 4 to 6.
And verses 4 to 6 really is a defining moment for the people of God. It is one of the most crucial
passages in the entire Old Testament actually. It's been described by commentators in a few different
ways. Let me just read you a couple. One of them said this is an intentional summary of the entire
Pentateuch. The Pentateuch is basically the first five books of the Bible. And He's saying
it's all summarized here in these verses. Another commentator described it as
Israel's mission statement. So if you look and say, well who is Israel? What are they to be about?
Summarized here. So this is their calling. The Lord who called Moses has also called them.
But the thing I also want us to see as we delve into these verses this morning is that
Lord who called them has also called us. So this passage isn't just speaking about
the Lord's calling of His people in a particular point in history. This is speaking about our
calling today. When you come to 1 Peter in the New Testament chapter 2 verse 9 there you see that
the very words that are used here are applied very specifically to the church. This is our
calling. Let me just say if you feel a bit adrift in regard to your calling this morning,
hopefully this will bring some clarity as it brings us back to the most fundamental things that we are
called to together as the people of God. So we're answering this question essentially.
What is our calling? What does the Lord say to us about it? Three things. First of all,
God calls us to Himself. So let's read verse 4 again. God says to them,
You yourselves have seen what I did to the Egyptians and how I bore you on eagle's wings and brought
you to myself. So before anything else the Lord calls His people to Himself. This is their calling.
They're called to Him. And here we see that their life with God didn't begin by them doing
something for God. It began with God doing something for them. What did He do? He brought them
to Himself. He saved them, brought them to Himself. Here we're reminded of what they were saved from.
So He talks about how they were saved from Egypt. You've seen what I did to the Egyptians. And by
the way, it's clear that He did this without any of their help. You've seen what I did. It's
what they did or what they did with Him. It's what they saw Him do. We've already seen time and time
again that this is a picture of how Christ saves us from sin and death. Slavery to those things.
But we also see not just what God saves them from. We see what God saves them for here.
God didn't just save them from Egypt. He saved them for a relationship with Himself.
Sure, God is leading His people to the promised land. But more than that, He is bringing them to
Himself. They were redeemed for relationship. And that relationship is with Him. And He uses a
beautiful picture to describe this relationship. So you can imagine the people there at Mount Sinai,
their eyes are lifted up. And so He uses a picture of something you might see as your eyes
are lifted up. It's a picture of an eagle caring for its young. He says,
Remember how I bore you on eagle's wings and brought you to myself.
So the picture here is this eagle caring for its eaglets. And that picture of the Lord
caring for us in this way is then brought up again in Deuteronomy 32 and verse 11. And
it elaborates a little bit further on this image. It describes how an eagle would
stir up its nest, creating discomfort for its eaglets. So why would it do that?
Well, so that they can learn that they need to move out and to fly on their own. You might
wonder, well, what if things don't go well? What then goes on to describe the image further
saying, it describes how an eagle spread out its wings to catch them and bear them up on its wings.
So the point being made here is that the Lord tenderly cares for His own. And sometimes like an eagle
stirring up its nest, that includes putting His people in unsettling situations where they need
to learn to trust Him. So where have we seen that already in the wilderness wondering? I'm
sure it won't take us too long to think about it. I mean, the Israelites had been experiencing
this kind of discomfort, this unsettling as God moved them from what they knew in Egypt,
out into the wilderness. There were times when they wished they were back in the nest, back in Egypt,
but God was bringing them into something better. It was a life with Himself where they learned
His goodness that He really can be trusted. You know, the Lord does the same thing with us.
I don't know if you've ever experienced where God kind of stirs up the nest you've been in
and puts you in an uncomfortable situation where you've got to learn to trust Him in that.
I think maybe the house move, you know, where you move house, or maybe a child, or maybe you've had to
move schools before. And the Lord stirs you up in that way and brings you into something else that's
new. Or maybe you're part of a church that doesn't know where it's going to be meeting and you're
kind of looking at the next venue and there's this kind of unsettling thing of like where are
we heading? You know, it can feel uncomfortable and unsettling, but in those times we can rest
assured that God is still at work for our good and He is, even when it's uncomfortable, we can
trust that He's still nudging us forward to show that we can trust Him and that we can step out
into this life of faith that He is leading us into. He does this that we might know Him more
and more deeply. You know, when Jesus began His ministry in Mark chapter 3, we see this
happening. He's already got a following. He's already proclaiming the kingdom and He calls His
disciples to Himself and there He calls the 12 to Himself and He names them apostles.
But in Mark chapter 3 and verse 14 we're told what He was going to do with them,
what His purpose was, what their calling was. It says, He called them that they might be
with Him and that He might send them out with authority. So do you see the order of the call?
What was the first thing that Jesus called His disciples to do? It was not to do something
for Him, it was to be with Him. So disciple, listen to this, the first call of a disciple is
the call to be with Christ. It is a life of apprenticeship with Him where we come to know
Him more and more. It is a life that is lived with Christ and by Christ. Of course this begins
when we become a Christian but that's not where it finishes. Think of a wedding, like weddings are
good and they are necessary but that isn't the end of the marriage, that's the beginning of it.
The life of that covenant is then lived out in practice together. So we come to know
Christ and then we're brought into this life with Christ that goes on all the way through.
You know, think about the Apostle Paul. He clearly knew the Lord and known Him for years when He
wrote the book of Philippians but in Philippians 3.10, here was Paul's longing. He said,
my longing is that I might know Him and the power of His resurrection and the fellowship
of His sufferings. Sure He knew the Lord but He knew there was so much more to know.
He wanted to know the Lord more and more deeply. He knew the Lord calls Him to Himself
so He calls us to Himself. So let's ask ourselves, do I know the Lord? Do I long to know Him more?
Because that's what He calls us to. Secondly, God calls us not only to Himself, He also calls
us to His purpose, to His purpose for our lives. So yes, Jesus called His disciples first to
be with Him but also to send them out with authority to fulfill His purpose for them.
And you see the same thing here at Sinai. You see the question at Sinai isn't so much,
how do we become God's people? Right? So God was remembering the covenant He made long ago with
Abraham. Right? They are the Lord's people. So the issue isn't how do we become the Lord's
people here at Sinai. It's how do we live together as the Lord's people? What does it mean to be
God's people and how do we live in light of that? Verses 5 to 6 answers that question. He says,
this is who you are. This is your purpose. You are my treasured possession, a kingdom of priests
and a holy nation. As we said before, this isn't just who they are. This is who we are
in Christ. This is who this is our purpose as the church. Let me read 1 Peter chapter 2 and verse 9.
I referenced it earlier but we didn't actually read it. So let me read it for us. This is what
said to the church, but you are a chosen race, a royal priesthood, a holy nation, a people for
his own possession that you may proclaim the excellencies of him who called you out of
darkness into his marvelous light. So what God says of the people of Israel then, he says of the church
now. This is who we are and why we are here. So let's take these one at a time, these descriptions.
So first of all, we are a treasured possession. God's treasured possession. When he says this,
he's conveying two things. One is belonging and the other is value. All right? So belonging.
So he says it here, all the earth is mine. All the earth belongs to him and yet there is a special
sense in which his people belong to him. I'm sure all of us know what it is to long to belong
or at least feel like we belong somewhere. You know, we could look all sorts of places to
find this. We could look at kind of where we're from, like who our people are, what our
hobbies are. We're looking like where do we fit in? Where do we belong? The fact is ultimately,
we are all made to know the comfort of knowing that we belong to the Lord. He is our home. He is
our dwelling place, as it says in Psalm 90, a psalm of Moses. This is where the longing
to belong is satisfied, to knowing that we belong to the Lord. I love the first question of the
Heidelberg Catechism. It says this, written a long time ago. It's questions and answers. It said,
the question, what is your only comfort in life and in death? Here's the answer, that I am not my own
but belong, body and soul in life and in death to my faithful Savior, Jesus Christ.
So the Lord says, you belong to me. Also, this is conveying value as well. Let's just say they're
his possession. They're his treasured possession. The word possession, here's a word that was used
to describe the treasure of kings. You see, God's people don't just belong to him, they are treasured
by him. Zephaniah 3.17 even says that he rejoices over us with singing. Several years ago,
Julia and I went to the Tower of London. You don't know what the Tower of London is. It's this historic
fortress on the Thames River in London, in central London. And there's lots of interesting things to
see when you go there. But like the most interesting thing to see, the thing they kind of promote the
most is the crown jewels. This is this collection of the British monarchies, kind of finest treasures
including the crown and all the regalia that's worn when there's a coronation that's kind of where it's
kept. So as you can imagine, when World War II happened and London was being bombed, they wanted
to keep the crown jewels safe. So they decided, here's what they were going to do to make sure
it was well secured. They stuck them in a cookie jar. They filled up this cookie jar with all
these jewels. So they felt, well, people will not think that they are in there if they are
looking for them. So they appeared unimpressive, but actually they were extremely valuable.
And that's the case with the people of God. You see, other nations might look on them,
this people wandering out in the wilderness, this homeless people and think, well, what is so
special about them? They don't appear to be any greater or better than other people. And the
fact is, the answer is they weren't better. They weren't greater. What made them special was that
God mercifully set His love upon them and chose them as His own. He didn't treasure them because
they somehow earned His favor as a people. No, He loved them because He loved them. That's why.
And this is true of everyone who is in Christ. If you are in Him, you are treasured by God.
Ephesians 1.18, there we are described as the Lord's inheritance. He treasures us.
The Lord loves us not because we have somehow made ourselves better and more desirable to Him,
and He's kind of responding to us in His love. No, it's the other way around. He loves us because
He's chosen to love us. He treasures us. However others see us, we can live in the assurance
that we belong to God who loves us and treasures us. Another thing about the crown jewels is,
today they are not treasured in secret. Actually, they're treasured right out there in the open.
You can go see them. They want you to see them. And so that brings us to the next thing, because
God treasures His people, not just in a kind of secret way. He treasures His people in such a
way that He wants to display His glory through them to the rest of the world. He wants this
treasure to be seen because it reflects Him. So what does He say? He says,
You're my treasured possession and You're also my kingdom of priests. You shall be to me a kingdom of
priests. This is speaking of when He's talking about them being priests and speaking of their,
yes, their access to God, but also their role as God's representatives. Because priests had this
role. They represented man before God, but they also represented God before man. And this was
the role that God's people were given in relation to other nations. Yes, they had priests within them,
but as a whole, they were to be priests in the world. In other words, they represented the Lord
before humanity, before the nations of the world. And ultimately they were doing this, that they
might bring the nations to the Lord. The priests is the purpose. But also they are, notice
the kingdom language. They are kingdom representatives. This is going back to, I mean, all the way back to
Genesis. Do you remember the purpose of humanity, the purpose statement there? We were created in
the image of God, but also God gave us dominion over the earth. We were created to live in
such a way that images forth our Creator, the Creator who reigns over all things,
to live under His reign and have dominion in the earth. Of course, we then choose to rebel against
Him and go our own way. But here, here at Sinai, God tells Israel that this is the role that they
are to fulfill as His people. They are to live together under the Lord's reign. And as they
do that, they are His kingdom representatives in the world. You see, the God of Israel was not
a tribal deity. Yes, he was their God. There was this covenant relationship that is there. And yet,
all the earth belongs to him. So the purpose of the Exodus and God bringing His people to Himself was
to use the language that He used to Pharaoh in Exodus 9.16, so that His name might be proclaimed
in all the earth. So yes, this relationship is special, but it's not purely for their
sakes. It's for all the earth to know the Lord. And this is our calling. 1 Peter 2.9, once again,
God's made us His own so that we might proclaim the exalancies of Him who called us out of darkness
and into His marvelous light. And there it describes us as a royal priesthood, combining
royal and priesthood there together. We are His royal representatives. We are citizens of God's
kingdom, but that doesn't mean we isolate ourselves in a fortress with the gate raised up. No, we
raise the banner, we fling the gate open wide, and we declare the glories of our great king. We
invite people to come to know Him as their Savior and King as well. We are His priests
in the world. This is true of every believer. We have been given access to God through Christ,
but also we represent Him before others and have the aim of bringing them to the Lord as well.
This is true locally with the people that we know or related to or work with, but also it's true
globally. We're called to take our part in making Christ known to the ends of the earth.
And that can't happen without what He says next. He says, this is your purpose. You're my treasured
possession, my kingdom of priests, but also a holy nation. There should be holy. They are holy. In
other words, they're set apart. At Sinai we have this powerful demonstration of the holiness of
God, His glory, the public display of His holiness. And His people are called to be holy as He is
holy. How is God's name going to be made known in the world? But here's the answer. It is as we
reflect His holiness in the world. So we proclaim His name, but we also do that in such a way that's
also showing who He is and how we live as well. How could we possibly proclaim His name if our
lives don't reflect His likeness? How can we say that Jesus is King if we are the actual ones
who are ruling over our lives or giving ourselves over to something else? So 1 Peter chapter 2,
once again, after He says what He does in verse 9, on to verse 12, it says this,
therefore keep your conduct among the Gentiles, among the peoples of the world
honorable. This is a word for non-Christians. Keep your conduct among them honorable,
so that when they speak against you as evil doers, they may see your good deeds and
glorify God on the day of visitation. So our lives are to be a reflection of the holiness of God.
The likeness of Jesus is to be seen in us, and it's through that that God's name is made known
in the world. This brings us to the last point. So God calls us to Himself,
God calls us to His purpose. Lastly, we see that God calls us to a life of obedience.
In verse 5, we see that it is through obedience that they would fulfill their calling as the people
of God. Now therefore, if you will obey my voice and keep my covenants, you shall be my treasure
possession, kingdom of priests, holy nation. So it isn't their obedience once again that brought
them into this covenant relationship with God, but it is how they are to live out this
relationship. It's how they were to live as His covenant people in the world,
live in a way that's consistent with their calling. It's a life of obedience to the Lord.
So what does this life of obedience look like? Well, it's about to be spelled out in the giving
of the law, which we are going to look at next week. But for now, however, they've not been
given the content of what it is they are to obey. Nevertheless, there is something significant
for us to learn here about why we should obey the Lord's word. So why are they to obey?
You see, here they are being called to an open-ended commitment to obey God's voice,
simply because He is the one who is speaking. His word is going to be delivered by Moses,
but these are the very words of God, and therefore they are to respond accordingly.
And if there was any doubt, it was the Lord who was speaking at Sinai. If they thought, well,
maybe these are just the words of Moses, not really the words of God. He makes it clear
that it's Him speaking by this spectacular display that we described earlier at Sinai.
They're the second half of the chapter. And that's not just conjecture saying that that's
what He's doing. Notice verse 9 with me. He says, Behold, I am coming to you in a thick cloud.
For this reason, that the people may hear when I speak with you and may also believe you forever.
God's making it clear that it is His word that Moses is bringing down from the mountain.
So why should we obey the Lord? Why should we obey His word? Because He's the one speaking.
Let's break that down in a couple of ways. One is because of His authority, that's why we should
obey Him. This is why we submit to the authority of scriptures because of the authority of the one
who gave the word. You know, the truthfulness and effectiveness of the scriptures, of the Bible,
have been proven over generations, over thousands of years, and that is compelling. It really is,
but that is not ultimately the reason why we follow them or why we believe them.
We submit to their authority because they proceeded from the very mouth of God to use the language of
Jesus. You see, this is how we should approach the scriptures. We should have a posture of surrender
before the Lord, even before we know what He's going to say to us. We should come and say,
Lord, the answer is yes. We should sign our name at the bottom of the blank page and say,
Lord, say whatever you want to say. The answer is already yes. You know, if a buddy messages me
and says, hey, can you do something for me? I'm probably going to wait before I respond to that
message because I want to know what they're asking of me. Like, what do you want me to
actually do? And then I'll let you know. That cannot be how we relate to God because He is God.
We're called to this posture of surrender because of who He is. He's the Lord of heaven and earth.
Our response mustn't be, Lord, tell me what it is you want me to do and then I'll think about it.
It should be, Lord, you're God. So tell me whatever it is because I want to follow you.
But there's another motivation for obedience here. It's not just His authority. It's also
His grace. It's His grace. God is gracious. And therefore, we want to live before Him in a posture
of gratitude and trust for the grace that He has shown to us. You see, there's a pattern here.
Don't miss this pattern because it's going to flow throughout the rest of Scripture.
The Lord saves His people. Therefore, they serve Him. And it has to be that way around.
We've got this wonderful revelation of God's grace there in verse four. Remember what I've
done for you. And because of that, I want you to follow me in obedience. So in other words,
our lives are lived in grateful response to what God has done to bring us into this relationship
with Himself. We don't serve Him in order that we might be His own, but because He has made
us His own. The fact is, the more we are seeing of His grace, the more obeying Him will be
something that we really want to do. Yes, what we see as authority, we say obeying Him is something
we ought to do. And that's right. Seeing His graciousness, we say, that's what I want to do
because He's so good. If He saved me, I know I can trust Him. And I know that He gives me His
word that it is for my good as well as His glory. You see, He leads us into a life of
obedience from the heart. And let me tell you, this is something that I struggle with. That's
why I know that you struggle with it too. We all struggle to obey the Lord and to do so from the heart.
And you know, you see the struggle in the life of Israel. As you read Exodus, they don't even
make it away from the foot of Sinai before they turn away from the Lord and they're
disobeying His word in all kinds of egregious ways. And that too is a pattern that's
repeated from generation to generation. But the Lord wasn't finished. Because all of this was pointing
to a new and better covenant that was going to be fulfilled by Jesus when He came into the world.
You see, the Lord who descended on Mount Sinai would descend once again,
by this time in the person of His Son. And through Christ, He would establish a new covenant
to Jesus as God incarnate. And He lived in a way that perfectly fulfilled His calling.
He succeeded where Israel failed. He lived a life of perfect obedience on behalf of His own.
And then He ascended to Mount Sinai, but it wasn't Mount Sinai, it's Mount Calvary. And there on the
cross, He took our sin upon Himself and He died in our place. And there He established a new
and better covenant by His blood. You know, compare those two mountains, that Sinai we see,
that boundary of death that separates us from a holy God. But at Calvary, we see that we are
invited into the very presence of God because Christ died in our place.
You know, the people of Israel were told in no uncertain terms because of the holiness of
God do not touch this mountain. But after Jesus' resurrection, what did He say to
doubting Thomas? He said, place your finger in my hands.
And your hand in my side.
Yes, the Lord is holy, but He is so gracious and His grace is revealed to us in Jesus.
The covenant that He has established through His sacrificial death. This is the Lord who
is calling us to come to Him this morning. You see, He even invites us to His table
where He says to us, take and eat. This is my body, which is broken for you.
So we draw near to Him, not because we are worthy, but because the one who made the way
for us is calling us to come to Himself. He says, I want you to come to me. I've made you my own.
So may we all come to Him by faith this morning.